de cádiz al hotel de ville la socialista
anne hidalgo es alcaldesa de parís desde
el 2014
procedente de una familia obrera tuvo
que emigrar de españa' lyon cuando tan
sólo tenía dos años debido a la
represión franquista allí consiguió la
doble nacionalidad y cambió su nombre de
anna a no considerándose francesa por
voluntad estudió derecho mientras
trabajaba como niñera para costearse sus
estudios tras los que se convirtió
inspectora de trabajo antes de mudarse a
parís donde lanzar su carrera política
desde que entró a la alcaldía la
política del partido socialista ha
encabezado la revolución verde acelerada
en la capital por la pandemia con el
aumento del uso de las bicicletas y las
restricciones a los coches
estamos en un momento muy especial de
nuestra historia somos la última
generación que puede actuar antes de que
sea demasiado tarde el domingo los
parisinos nos dieron la responsabilidad
de actuar
con dos mandatos consecutivos al frente
de parís hidalgo también ha impulsado
las políticas sociales y se autodenomina
feminista con la lucha por la igualdad
de género en su programa político
dependerá de las mujeres decidirlo
dependerá de los franceses decidirlo
serán ellos quienes transmitan la idea
de que las mujeres en puestos de
responsabilidad marcan una diferencia
positiva en la vida de las mujeres y los
hombres hidalgo ha tenido que lidiar con
la pandemia y el movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos y su carta de
izquierda moderada despierta pasión y
odio entre los franceses con
aspiraciones a la presidencia sigan así
la carrera al elíseo se convertiría en
la primera presidenta mujer inmigrante
de francia